good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Friday it's a gloomy Friday in New
York but the weather looks like how we
feel
hey Claude how you doin I'm gonna have
it looked outside yeah but you know what
I don't need to know I don't need the
weather to tell me how to feel because
I'm depressed this is just actually one
of my favorite types of weather days
because it doesn't cast too much light
into my apartment and I can catch a vibe
like more easily than when the Sun is
reflecting on my mirrored dresser and
then it's poking me in the eye and it's
just problematic so I just love a good
cloud I love when it rains in quarantine
I wonder if I'm the only one that was
dark that was a dark statement I like
the weather it doesn't bring any light
into my apartment um
why like who needs brightness when
you're not trying to do anything I agree
it's just it's facts man also like when
you're sleeping in who wants to sunshine
peering through the shades do you black
out shades I do but they don't encompass
my whole window still so I still get
little slivers which I like I wouldn't
want my room to be completely black or
else I would never wake up yeah I used
to have like our trades and it was bomb
but my apartment now like you could see
in the back there sheer I liked it for
like a few reasons but I don't like it
for a few reasons as well yeah I think
being able to wake up like with the
natural light is ideal but sometimes you
just want it to be dark as hell totally
especially if you have a migraine yeah
totally so are you auditioning for
Pretty Little Liars today is that what
we're going for
yes I'm auditioning for the role of the
girl who hasn't washed her hair since
Monday and she didn't want to put any
huh maid in it to make it more oily so
she decided to cover her flyaways with
her hood they're equals so you're
auditioning for the role of a whoever a
maybe I just saw a final Pretty Little
Liars tick-tock I don't know if a had
flyaways because she never took her um
her hood off but you know who did suffer
from flyaways was trying Belisario and
people tell me that I look like her so
maybe I'm auditioning for Spencer
perhaps also maybe a like resorted to
the hood in the fur
place because of the fires maybe she was
a terrorist maybe she was so embarrassed
um I never watched the show and I'm sure
this is a loaded question but like who
ended up being a so I actually just saw
really funny take talked about it last
night about how like most shows it's
like mystery solution and then they did
this whole like funny thing with all
these different things that happen along
the way of like Spencer's a Spencer's
twin is a like Mona's a Ezra's a it was
really funny so I guess everyone has a
little bit of a in them inspiring story
mm-hmm beautiful it's beautiful well we
have a great show for you today
because we have a lot to recap we're
recapping Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills Kardashians and too hot to handle
I finished the show yesterday it was
really enjoyable it's like exactly my
kind of show and I liked that it was so
short they said that they were filming
for a month but that was not a month
there was no way because like for the
first few episodes they just got there
and then the last few episodes it's like
there's only a few days left
right I mean I wasn't complaining but um
that's just it is what it is you know
yeah you can't lie to me you can't lie
to me also we did something so fun
yesterday and I don't say this often I
say it sometimes but not every time I
think our most favorite patreon video
ever dropped yesterday people are loving
it we did in all steams on deck zoom
happy hour and filmed it we took a lot
of your questions which I moderated it
was just so funny I rewatched the first
ten minutes and I was laughing so hard
it was like painfully funny because it
was like painful um so if you are
looking for some extra premium content
today check that out patreon.com slash
the morning toast it's just gonna open
up a world of content for you and I'm
jealous of the experience you're about
to have ya know it was really fun and it
was like very sisterly very very
sisterly those sisters they're they're
really something you know those crazy
kids crazy kids okay well I mean I don't
have much else to say you know what I
watched a little bit last night of the
draft the NFL Draft
did you know been watching I happen to
be making dinner when it was turning 8
o'clock so I was like you know what I
want to see how they're due
and I thought it was so well done it was
not sad at all it was really cool um
ESPN just did a great job of like Roger
Goodell basement to the all the players
some of the players have the house of
the teams they were gonna join already
so I thought it was really a lesson and
how to do these things virtually because
it I did not find it to be sad I thought
it I thought it was like really cool use
of technology I'm so happy for the
players you know if I thought it was
gonna be sad and if it's not you're
telling me and it's not then that's
great that means everyone had a good
time and that means we're getting better
as a society we are once again striding
towards better Ness to you know turnout
premium content because in the beginning
of this quarantine some of the [ __ ] I
was seeing was a disgrace disgrace and I
mean it wasn't I'm sure it wasn't as
great for them as if they had been in
Sin City sending it up but it wasn't sad
I can't like watching NFL Draft without
thinking about the movie draft day which
is like really one of my favorite movies
and every time like a player got picked
or didn't get picked I was just like
it's because they didn't go to his
birthday party cuz yeah you know Kevin
Costner knew like in order to be a
teammate like you've got to throw down
with the team and the team doesn't want
to throw down with you you're not gonna
be a good teammate yeah if you haven't
seen the movie draft day you need to
watch it like it tells you everything
you need to know about the NFL Draft
when I watch the draft I always think
like I can't tell if these people know
that they're getting picked or they
don't cuz they're like never really
surprised but Ben says that they don't
really know for sure
yeah because anything can happen out in
draft a and that's the moral of the
story of the movie draft day it's like
you think you know you think you could
be the best quarterback like in the
league but no one came to your birthday
party and Kevin Costner figure that out
and you don't know that that's like a
red flag for him devastating if that
were the case then I would lose because
nobody ever comes to my birthday parties
yeah no you would I don't know if Kevin
Costner would pick you but yeah Congrats
to all the players who were drafted
fabulousness
exciting looking forward to an exciting
future football for you Joe borough
Congrats number one pick yeah Ben was
talking about him like all night and
he's hot oh my god I did something so
funny last night that I should have
filmed but I didn't even think of it
when Zach was like washing up for
and I was laying in the bed I was on
Twitter and I saw these like trending
topics about who was picked who wasn't
picked someone liked the controversies
and I was just like oh my god can you
believe that like Green Bay drafted a
quarterback when they have Aaron Rodgers
I was just quoting these headlines
verbatim true he would say yeah no it
was true but I was just like trying to
have an intellectual sports conversation
with him he thought I was live-streaming
him but I wasn't and it was really funny
devastating news for Rodgers well I mean
it's just like a little shot day but see
crazy things are happening in the draft
makes you think makes you think also
speech speaking of virtual content I saw
that Saturday Night Live is doing
another like Saturday night from home
and I don't really know why yeah I
watched watched Robin slide last night
and I know I came out here yesterday I
was like raving about the episode with
Erika and Meghan McCain and maybe it's
because Meghan McCain has like a virtual
show every day she like knows when to
speak it's really only speak when spoken
to that's like how our patreon was last
night
um but something about last night's
episode was so messy like Wendy
McClinton had the worst Wi-Fi connection
she looked so blurry you kept talking
over everyone like and then her and Andy
would both try to talk and they would be
like no you go like it was really bad
really not good well you know what we
don't watch a lot of these virtual
at-home shows but apparently that's
something that a lot of people are
starting with like talking over each
other I watched both episodes of watch
what happens live because you braved
about the other one and I did want to
see Leah McSweeney and I likes them both
I agree the quality was better Meghan
McCain is a pro the view has actually
you know I watched a clip of the view um
an episode from last week or something
and it was actually more enjoyable
because the women are not able to talk
over each other and you just hear one
person at a time and I saw who's really
good for them I read in The Hollywood
Reporter for the first time in eight
years the view has out-beat Ellen in
ratings Wow yeah pretty cool pretty cool
I also watched um what did I watch
virtually that I wanted to oh somebody
posted a clip of the Seth Meyers show
having John Mulaney on he like
maleeni during quarantine as i started
to watch Real Housewives of New York and
I guess I thought that would be like a
funny bit now I understand that I may be
not like John Mulaney has a very
specific brand of comedy and people like
died for him and admittedly like I don't
really get the whole shtick but I think
he's funny obviously this was like and
someone posted in the toasters and
people were like living for it and I
literally never been more bored in my
whole life they also were having
problems with the oh oh and then like
John Lane he thought he was being so
funny about how housewives like makes
him miss 71st and third like it was not
funny like if I thought if male comedian
is watching season one Real Housewives
of New York like that is comedy gold
like there's so much there and I just
like didn't think it was funny like
maybe it was the format I just wasn't
into it he was like sitting in this
kid's bedroom it was not good hmm okay
like I should check it out but I know
that I want especially since you're
saying it's not good I'm all sad I'd
rather just watch Real Housewives
because last night's episode was some of
the greatest of all time yeah this week
between Beverly Hills Kardashian's New
York I don't really include pump rules
because it's like turning into a bad
show but it's been really premium like
three of three yeah I completely agree
okay but I think it's time to just get
into the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but I think I've
something to say is that okay with you
so the gyms are closed right but you
want to stay active and get fit sign up
for daily burn at daily burn calm and
give at home workout to try for 30 days
it's free if you want motivation daily
burns professional trainers have plenty
to spare if you hate training alone you
can join a group session every weekday
there's a program that fits your needs
and your fitness levels and you can get
your 30 day free trial signup a daily
burn now at daily burn dot-com sign up
for daily burn a daily burn com you can
get fit have fun and repeat with daily
burn at daily burn dot-com slash toast I
think that jelly burn is fabulous um and
I like doing a group session Margeaux
actually inspired me she said she did
like a workout with her friends over
FaceTime and it was like so fun and then
they took it to like a formal class on
daily burn and she said it was so fun
and I did a group training session and
it was really fun like it makes it more
enjoyable yeah it does but then
sometimes you want the one-on-one I love
that they have both I'm loving
switching up all of my different
workouts at home and daily burn has been
fabulous so make sure to go to daily
burn dot-com love it sign on get your
daily burn ok first story I have a coach
[ __ ] nearly burnt I come / toast get
yourself 30 days free only if you use
daily burn calm / toast sweet ok sign on
getcha daily burn first story we're just
gonna get right into it into an argument
this morning because Taylor Swift is
back on the IG story um
letting everyone know that scooter and
big machine are hosting an album of hers
without her permission this is what she
said hey guys I want to thank my fans
for making me aware that my former
record label is putting out a quote
album of live performances of mine
tonight this recording is from a 2008
radio show performance I did when I was
18
Big Machine has listed the date as to
2017 release but they're actually
releasing it tonight at midnight I'm
always honest with you guys about this
stuff so I just wanted to tell you that
this release is not approved by me it
looks to me like Scooter Braun and his
financial backers 23 capital Alex Soros
and the Soros family and the Carlyle
Group have seen the latest balance
sheets and have realized that paying
three hundred and thirty million dollars
for my music wasn't exactly a wise
choice and they need money crying face
crying laughing face in my opinion just
another case of shameless greed in the
time of coronavirus so tasteless but
very transparent wait I don't know why
we're gonna disagree I think this is
hilarious
um what's hilarious about it well I
think that it's like whenever Taylor
release is something like obviously her
fans listen to it because they love her
and they listen to it but it's also like
it you're showing it an act of support
like you support you buy albums you
stream like and so if something came out
that people just assumed was Taylor's
album like they would buy stream support
because it's hers but she just wanted
everyone to know like I had absolutely
nothing to do with this but I think
everybody does know that anything that
was like before the lover era that she
had to part with when she left big
machine we all know that like they were
thinking of doing rerelease it like that
this could be done like that we have
heard of the deal of the business deal
was made between them in 2020 like a new
album comes out like with Taylor's name
on it like not everyone would assume
that Taylor didn't approve it no but I
think at this point like we very much
know that there is a break in her work
and some people own one piece of it and
she owns the other piece and when it
comes to all that earlier stuff like she
does not own that if I heard a record of
her singing on a 2008 radio station show
like I'm like oh this has big machine
written all over it
well that also begs the question like
who thought that this was a good idea
like let's say they are trying to like
make money like use the stuff that they
bought to generate some sort of revenue
to make back the 330ml like what radio
performance is gonna break the bank yeah
I have no idea also I went to Spotify
this morning I didn't see anything that
was like recording like a new album by
Taylor Swift so I wonder if they just
like stopped the project yeah I mean
it's obvious what the point of her
Instagram story was because I'm sure if
she hadn't posted anything like it would
have performed better in streams in
sales than it would now that people know
that like she doesn't approve it and
she's basically and no she's not mincing
words she's saying don't buy it don't
stream it like I didn't approve this and
I'm gonna pour it yeah but there is no
album unless so I don't know it was
suppose she said they're releasing it
tonight at midnight and nothing I didn't
see any unless it's not on Spotify but
yeah I mean I hadn't even heard of it
like I have it and I'm like you know in
I have a tumblr like I'm in the Taylor
circuit um and I didn't see any rumors
about an alleged album but I'm sure she
did some research she don't worry yeah
nope
oh I'm sure like there there was
something happening but maybe it's just
not happening anymore or maybe it's like
postponed do you think that three
hundred thirty million dollars was too
much money to pay for her six albums I
don't know how like music money works
maybe there that seems like what she
honestly I feel like her catalogue would
be worth even more than that you know
like [ __ ] how do you make your money
back on three hundred and thirty million
dollars of songs that you bought just
like hoping people stream it no like
also getting songs in commercials
getting songs in
these you know uh just yet people still
are buying albums etc will be releasing
songs from a live show in 2008 like yeah
and they've been doing like a few shady
things like they released like a limited
edition vinyl of Taylor's you know first
single Tim McGraw which a lot of like
real fans would genuinely want but the
heart diehards didn't buy it because
it's a big machine and then they also
I've actually I listen to a Spotify
playlist called um the Taylor Swift
catalog and they have like every album
ever put out and that includes like
weird albums and there's like a big
machine release of speak now where like
Taylor talks to some woman at the
beginning it's really in a way I don't
know if that's new from the big machine
drama or it existed before but I've only
recently noticed it yeah you know what I
noticed I'm the quarren seems playlist I
think it's like a bright young album it
says on the cover like a big machine
release I get was something special
right than then the initial album
release so maybe that's just something
that they do yeah I just don't know the
timeline of it but I assume that was an
opportunity to make money I just the
music industry is so confusing
especially with streaming and there's so
many artists who are so rich but like
Taylor's rich obviously from her music
but like from merch from tour from so
much other stuff like I don't know how
songs generate revenue especially when
Taylor still makes money on them because
she's the songwriter on almost every
song or every song so songwriters always
make money no matter who the label is so
I don't know it's very confusing yeah it
is confusing but honestly that 2008 live
album sounds like really great right now
I know I will I will pirate it for sure
that's totally the vibe I'm going for
you know like those are actually the
songs that I have um like for the
quarren scenes like it's not like I have
reputation songs that I'm listening to
it's really like fearless speak now oh
yeah of course I actually um I don't
know whether it was like Taylor's
Instagram story that like pushed me into
this spiral last night where I watched
MS Americana documentary again I haven't
seen it since we all saw it in theaters
and I actually had like such an
appreciation I don't think I ever said
thank you tomorrow who like in advance
like bought tickets like we had such a
good night like we got to see miss
Americana in theaters at I
like it was only like a 30 person
theater so I need to text her thank you
um and I watched a documentary again and
I totally forgot about that song only
the young that she put like wrote for
the documentary okay are you ready for
our next story mm-hmm
cuz Ariana Grande is lashing out at
degrading tik-tok impersonators oh my
god there's two they come up on my
[ __ ] this girl Gabby and that's the
girl that was in the break up with your
boyfriend video so Ariana kind of like
gave in a little bit and then this other
girl Paige no she's not really talking
about just like the two big culprits she
this is what she posted and then of
course deleted it because that's the re
way she said oh my god can I stop and
this please also double as your
impression of the ponytail
tick-tock girls who think doing the cat
valentine voice and that wearing winged
eyeliner and a sweatshirt is doing a
good impersonation of me because this
really happy how it feels crying sad
emoji like not laughing sad quote
degrading its entire value ice cream so
she was replying or like going off of
this other mean that's called like
impressions of the meme which was by a
creator named Jordan Firstman that like
do great this is what I said the video
where he calls out mean creators who
recontextualize and assign quote a
completely arbitrary meaning to a moment
the original creator quote loved so much
kind of like degrading its entire value
got it okay so it really sounds like
Ariana's speaking directly to this girl
page like she wears her hair permanently
in ari's high pony and she wears
eyeliner and she does like little
voiceovers to Kat from from Victorious
like Lana moon I'm on the moon like it's
so good I know I've been watching wait
one too many page videos and all the
comments were like get your own identity
and they're like being so mean to this
girl but it's so losery yeah and I think
also for ariana grande like when it's
like everyone's about to do an
impression parent I feel like she's had
a good um a good attitude about the
sweatshirt hand impressions like ariana
grande at Thanksgiving Ariana Grande
your hands like she can make fun of
herself but like when every time someone
goes to do an ariana grande impression
it's from a character from like 12 years
ago who I don't think she relates to at
all she's so much more than that like
truly she's a global pop star icon so I
do think it is quote degrading its
entire value when you just are like oh
I'm ariana grande I'm gonna be cat no
totally and we're like red fiery red
hair yeah totally I respect I respect I
just think I understand why she said
that but then I also understand why she
deleted it cuz she's really only talking
to like two people and they're just not
worth her time
no she's talking to two people and one
of them has like the ariana grande seal
of approval because Ariana put her in
that music video so the other is just
like washed-up and it's obviously about
her yeah um that's really funny though
I'm sure it gets so annoying for her she
weirdly sees everything about herself on
the internet like she is so salmon with
her phone away she's got to put her
she's got to put her phone away like how
do her wrists not hurt like mine I feel
like she's a small wrist girl I well so
yesterday I watched I've been talking
about my youtube channel um YouTube app
on my TV and it's been really
inspirational and they've been
suggesting new stuff for me which is so
nice like they know what I want and
yesterday I actually watched a
three-hour one love Manchester concert
which was like a weird and dark thing to
do but I don't remember ever seeing it
in full and I just have to say it was
fabulous like it was really inspiring
and like ariana really put that show on
her shoulders and she's like so little
in so many ways like obviously physical
but I just feel like she's like Leto in
general and it was like a really brave
thing for her to do and like she
literally carried the show like she
literally came out with every single
person like saying their songs did her
songs and then like at the beginning
that show the middle to show the end the
show and it was really fabulous and I
just like forget about that moment in
time where so many people like dropped
what they were doing within a weeks
notice like showed up for this concert
and like it wasn't sad like they had a
lot of stars
ya know is amazing yeah she's a great
gal you know she is a great gal and then
I was remembering like how we talked
about her so much on this show but I
don't really feel like because she's
done so much since that awful thing
happened but like that's so much a part
of who she is and I feel like I don't
give her
enough grace given what she went through
you know yeah so I'm gonna be a little
more graceful and like she's been
through even like so much more than that
you know with yeah like Mac Miller and
she's just she's one tough cookie and
Mac Miller came out and performed and
they performed her way together and then
this other song and like it was just so
cute like the whole concert was making
me cry like for more than one reason
right oh my god that's really sweet
okay next up Ricky Gervais is slamming
celebs who lecture quote normal nobodies
about coronavirus I literally love Ricky
Gervais so much brought to you by sin
fern if you're ready to make a lasting
impression sin bird can help you
discover your signature scent or keep
things fresh with new fragrances from
brands including til Ching Cabana Tom
Ford Versace and more sin bird is a
monthly monthly luxury perfume and
cologne subscription service with over
600 designer brands just choose the
fragrance you want to try in they'll
send you a 30 day supply in a travel
friendly refillable case to help you
find the perfect scent you can sort
their extensive collection by brand
style occasion season and more
plus they have products that go beyond
fragrance like skincare wellness and
makeup from best-selling brands like
Aparri glam glow glow recipe tart and so
many more sin bird is the definition of
everything of the sort I had been sumela
been started calling me stinky just
because like I've been taking showering
more it's like an elective than a
required course and having sent bird
just like a little spritz in my hair
really helps me from washing my hair
more than once week I love Stanford and
stinky thirty percent off your first
month today that's only ten dollars for
your first fragrance go to scent bird
comm slash Dean and used on a promo code
steam for 30% off your first month that
means your first perfume or cologne is
just $10
again that's SCE MTBI RDECOM / Steen to
sign up and use the promo code Steen ste
and sign on [ __ ] smell amazing oh I
love Sandford so much it's everything of
the sort really it's just like he said
okay Ricky Gervais is slimming celebs
just like we needed him to do just like
he's best at British funny man Ricky
Gervais again lashed out at
multi-millionaire celebs in a new
interview for lecturing quote normal no
bodies during the corona bye
outbreak he targeted the Wonder Woman
actress gal gadot and a crew of other a
listers such as Will Ferrell and Mark
Ruffalo for their viral cover of John
Legend's imagine he said on BBC Radio
quote that imagine video it's not that
bad they're probably very nice people it
was an awful rendition but they might
have been doing it for good reasons to
help these normal nobodies but they're
going quote my films coming out but I'm
not on telly I need to be in the public
eye not all of them but some of them you
can see in their eyes you could see it
in their I quote I could cry at the
beauty of my personality
I'm just so beautiful for doing this and
everyone sees that we get it so true and
I feel like this is exactly what we were
saying yesterday like someone could see
this what Ricky Gervais said as like a
little hypocritical because he himself
is a celebrity but to me there's such a
delineation between celebrities and
comedians and comedians really are able
to comment and like critique what's
going on in the world from like a third
party perspective they kind of forget
that they're like rich and famous
sometimes and I love Ricky Gervais and
that's the kind of energy he brought
when he hosted the Golden Globes
and that's the kind of energy he's
always bringing like a self-aware
celebrity and that's a rarity that's
like seeing a you know an exotic tiger
yeah he said for start you won't hear me
complain not when there's United Kingdom
National Health Service nurses doing
14-hour shifts and frontline workers
carrying on and risking their health I'm
fine don't worry about me I go for walks
on Hampstead Heath and we've got a
garden garden sounds nice he said that
privileged super starts don't have a
right to preach to the general public
during the crisis hear hear hear hear
I love him I've just been loving him
more and more um except for the
invention of lying but but it must be
nice for him because he's kind of um
created this like space for himself
where he really like doesn't get
backlash because his whole shtick is
like about backlash yeah must be my yeah
must be nice okay next door he's like
really crazy cuz Peter Krause is back in
the news and he's like explaining the
whole situation of what happened when he
was not the bachelor he went on Ben and
Ashley eyes podcast and did a
wide-ranging interview and it's just
spilling the tea so here's here it is
Peter said he rejected producers three
time
before flying out to LA for a quote
formal discussion about becoming the
bachelor quote I told the producers I
had started to talk to someone and they
said are you guys in a relationship I
said no and they said would you be
willing to leave that or exit that I
wasn't sure it was really hard for me
and I couldn't say I would for sure get
in an engagement at the end of the show
it wasn't that I knew for a fact that I
didn't want to it was more that I
couldn't promise them that I would and I
didn't want to be forced to do it if I
said yes to the show when the topic of
compensation came up Peter remembered
telling producers quote well I'm a
considerably more than that already per
year why would I give up the rest of my
life of being Peter the bachelor and no
longer just Peter for the amount of
money that isn't life changing
we all agreed it would it make sense to
pay a lot of money because you're no
longer doing it for the right reasons at
that point he said he denied that the
paycheck played a major factor in his
decision instead outlining a number of
more personal changes he wanted to see
come to fruition on the show this is
interesting this is what he wanted if he
was about sure that he didn't get quote
I wanted to be able to spend more time
with people individually I wanted to be
able to just go into the house and see
people in their natural habitat so that
way it didn't feel like they were
putting on a show for me it was more
like this is who you actually are when
your unsuspecting of where I'm at he
also requested relationship counseling
for myself and the top four or five
girls during the process so that we can
work things out on a deep level then I
wanted to continue to support for myself
in that person that I chose after the
fact because I saw the pressure there
Brian and Rachel were put under and I
thought it was extremely unfair he said
that in the end the producers could not
compromise and but he has no regrets
about the experience he is however still
looking for answers as to why just days
before filming began for bachelor Winter
Games producers texted him and said he
was no longer part of the cast he never
found out why he guessed that it was
because Ari was a bachelor at the time
and because I was the guy that could
have been the bachelor maybe they just
didn't want the conversation to be had
they just wanted to nip it in the bud
which I get he also said he would not go
on back to him paradise because the
women from who are coming up are just
too young and he's looking to date
someone over 30 and really like find a
partner interest Kelly Kelly
I mean like you know when you're going
through something like this like in real
time all all we wanted was answers like
why Peter Prince's promise like we
and so much and now we're like literally
being it's like served up on a platter
all the answers and like part of me just
doesn't care like it's too little too
late like we've had so many seasons
since the Peter debacle it's like I
can't even be bothered to care but if I
were to care what I would say was like
Peter sounded like he was being like way
too demanding like relax with your
couples counseling and like
restructuring the whole show like at the
end of the day was probably all about
money Peter didn't really want it but if
someone offers me five hundred grand all
right I'll do it I'm no shape to Peter
like it money's important and so is your
livelihood that you're leaving behind
like you built this gym like you built
this life in Wisconsin I totally respect
it but I'm sure it mostly had to do with
the money I think it was probably
everything like it doesn't seem like
they could agree on one point also
what's funny is we wanted all these
answers but now reading this it's like
oh it's exactly kind of what I thought
like the vibe of like not money to get
engaged like not like not being enough
money like just not enough incentive to
even do this um but all this stuff about
like couples counseling ones spend more
time with the girls it was like that's
kind of crazy that that's really why he
didn't do it like that that would be so
important to him that that's how
seriously he took this it's also funny
how far we've come in a sense where like
when Peter wanted to be the bachelor um
not getting engaged was like not an
option and now we like went off to
consecutive seasons where nobody got
engaged well it's kind of three because
of Hannah and Jed they got engaged but
like oh yes not now it's like getting
engaged is a rarity so Peter actually
put him in a Bachelor I feel like he
could still any look at Ari you know
look at Nick vile I feel like they could
call on him for look at Clare Crawley he
could be the bachelor eventually and
they'll pick women who are appropriate
for him and that like could still be in
the cards it could be because Clare
Carly is almost 40 right and so is Peter
yeah Peters 35 I think Clare's 35 or 36
cute yeah cute I mean I just I still
love him like of course he's just so
great
he's the prince who was promised I just
I can't believe that he really just went
back to life like like nothing ever
happened
he's like one of the few people who have
like acted like Fame wasn't what they
want and they were just like nominated
for the show by a friend and he's
the only person after Bachelor fame like
who has proven to me that he was really
not there for the fame and was genuinely
nominated by a friend yeah like like
everyone says that and then they're
making tick tock house cruise you know a
hundred percent yeah or sometimes you
can't help like oh my god I have all
these Instagram followers I need to sell
t like I need to tell this like I'm
gonna make all this money oh wow making
on this money from Instagram why would I
keep my job where I worked so hard and I
don't make money so like you kind of
stumble into it so it's not even like
you're good or a bad person for doing
that but he just like said no to all of
it all of it he's a cool dude
okay this and final story just like a
little Kardashian news before we got
into our recap Kanye West took his kids
to Wyoming to let Kim Kardashian have a
breaks as a source so um they have been
taking turns caring for the kids a
source is telling people magazine about
how the Kardashian West's are going
through quarantine um studying to become
a lawyer and running multiple businesses
wasn't already a full plate k'kaw has
also been raising her four kids while
practicing social distancing indoors the
reality star has been Kanye have been
alternating family responsibilities for
their children according to a source who
tells People quote it's a huge cast with
all their kids at home quote Kanye
escapes to his office for a work break
he also let Kim have a break last week
when he took some of the kids to Wyoming
they have been taking turns caring for
the kids I feel like some people might
think that this is weird if they're not
really all corentin´s together as a
family but I think it's genius yeah I'm
curious if they have live-in staff who
they let go home like I know they have
multiple nannies are they working I
think that some families who have staff
or nannies like I don't think everyone
is working but they're definitely not
doing it completely alone like they live
in if they're living in the house um
they might just still be working yeah
and I don't think that's against like
protocol for social distancing like if
you have a live-in staff like they can
say yeah as long as it had they had it
left in came back but if everyone
quarantined together like them were just
quarantine as a family right yeah um
hold on any tell my husband to stop
coughing okay
see see sorry always with all night last
night it was just [ __ ] nuts I'm
cracking yeah I understand I understand
well that's why I like you could have
been like Kim and Kanye and quarantined
separately in separate states switching
off with the kids like you take CEO for
one week oh my god precious angel man
lovey boy I miss him so much
that's what the show has been missing
he's in the love's hug that's what the
show is they're missing like our third
co-host he used to be there every day
snoring through every story and now it's
just the two of us hi Theodora you
turned around for the show he needs a
bath oh yeah that's what I'm gonna do
right after this he went over a little
he looks a little been texting me sorry
I was choking don't do it again come for
you um I just love the Kardashians like
I just I'm so happy for them like I just
hooked their quarantine okay I thought
lessons episode was great
it's fabulous yeah I I think it's it's
so it's nice if you can get it you know
like a fun women vibe in a Calabasas I'd
let's dive into the Kardashians recap
which will be our entire TV recaps
Eggman twitch is brought to you by
betterment it can be hard to know how to
reach your financial goals even in the
best times betterment betterment is here
to help you reach those goals and make
the most of your money from the cash you
see for tomorrow and the money you
invest for retirement how while
investing involves risk betterment is is
designed to take care of the hard stuff
and help you do what's right with your
money first we'll ask you some questions
about what you're saving for and then
build you a portfolio based on your
needs then they'll provide ongoing
expert guidance in the app itself to
help you make smart decisions with your
money they can give you advice on
accounts you don't have with betterment
they'll help you stay on track for your
goals with tax saving features and easy
to use like easy to use tools like
automatic deposits and you get
everything for one of the lowest fees in
the industry since 2010 betterment has
helped half-a-million people manage more
than eighteen billion dollars of their
money download the betterment app from
Google Play or the Apple App Store to
get started today love it
sweet sign on get betterment she ends it
was the birthday week I did I always
forget there's like always like a month
where like there's a cluster of events
like a million parties and it seems like
the Kardashians are everywhere and then
they like disappear and do it all again
a year later and I guess that happens in
November the end of October early
November news we started with Kendall's
party and just they weren't like really
filming they were just like showing all
the rich people who were there but what
I did find fascinating was that Kylie
threw the whole party for Kendall which
I'm assuming means she paid for it yeah
but also Kylie just has like an
imagination about her where she's just
capable of throwing fabulous parties
that other people don't seem capable of
doing right like having cocktail
waitresses dressed as Kendall from the
Met Gala like inspired inspired I like
that they showed us like a little bit of
the party I didn't expect you know to
get like confessionals from hailey
Bieber
but it was cool to be there I loved this
episode like it had everything and very
little Courtney which was just what made
it so great like even Chloe's egg
freezing journey which just feels like
you know a contrived storyline but I
definitely do think she's freezing her
eggs and this is something that's very
top of mind for her and I love that like
Tristan is her sperm donor that I think
they're like the way that they're
communicating and co-parenting is so
cute and I do have a little bit of a
ship for them yeah I didn't think it was
a contrived storyline I just definitely
felt like they put so much content about
it in this episode probably due to the
fact that Chloe is like one of the only
sisters who actually [ __ ] films so
like they had no choice but to include
it but it was like a little it was just
a little much like there was just a lot
of it in the episode but I like Chloe
and I'm happy for her and like I'm glad
she's getting her fertility health in
check yeah and I'm glad that she has
options and like that she can has can do
what she want and make the choice that
she wants to make that she thinks is
best for her family I love that they
plan that birthday for Cory I thought
that that was so nice I loved Cory like
he I think he's so great
I think he's the perfect like step-dad
guy for them and I did we ever see that
fight at that restaurant where he said
like I'm not your dad like I'm more of
your peer so it's kind of yes yeah but
it's so uncomfortable I barely remember
it yeah there's always but there's been
a few episodes with like weirdness with
Cory but like the kids smacking thing
and they never really like come to a
conclusion so I don't know if they don't
like Cory but I think there's definitely
like a separation in Chris's life like
he doesn't come to every meal like most
partners
so I like feeling these days I feel like
right now in present time I think things
are really good like remember before the
queue like Kylie was out with Corey and
her friends all the time like Corey was
always taking them places I think Kylie
really likes Corey I think the girls are
probably just more skeptical of him cuz
he's their age how would you feel if
your mom was eating someone your age
yeah and do you feel my call like when I
was watching him on the plane he it's a
you know how like you start to look like
the person you're dating he's like
started to age himself look he's a
little bit of a dad bod like a gray
beard and he was just like sitting with
his tequila and I'm like you know what
you actually looked like an
age-appropriate man for Cristiano right
now I thought the same thing at a
different point when they were like in
nap I was just like he's getting older
and more like her age he's embracing it
where I feel like maybe normally he
would like shave his beard if it's
turning gray but I think he just wants
to look more Christian or speed and it's
working ya know I I think everything
about them is working maybe there's like
there must be if the girls are like and
there's obviously stuff that we don't
see um but I just want Chris to be happy
she deserves it like after her lifetime
of everything that she's been through
and this is it for her so I'm glad that
the girls um did something and surprised
him but it was really sad when they
weren't invited to the dinner cuz like
Chris probably assumed that they
wouldn't want to be there and then it
was like too little too late but it made
me really want to go to Napa I mean also
I think this show is so great obviously
like we love them we love their family
blah blah blah like it's so glamorous
but I think like just the way that they
spend their money it like just makes
everyone like so eager to just give them
all of our money it's like wow you're
living the life that he's dream yeah
that trip to Napa looked so fun and you
could tell Chris was so happy like
obviously she gets drunk at any winery
but I just really felt like she was like
so happy that like it's obviously
something that's like been an issue and
it was like finally coming together and
it was like her kids and her boyfriend
like she just looked like she was happy
and having so much fun I don't really
know why Courtney came she was gonna
like sulk the whole time but I was glad
that she was there because Kim doesn't
drink and like that's like the one thing
I just like yeah with Kim so I was glad
Chloe had someone to drink with yeah and
Chris yeah and
Kim flew I think straight from Sonoma to
Houston for the Rodney Reed meeting
which that whole thing I can't believe
they got so much of it on camera like
it's such a historic moment like I just
I thought it was fabulous
I love the way Kim looked and when they
went to McDonald's oh my god that was
literally the best moment ever like
those girls behind the the window were
so cute and like screaming and I'd love
how they knew it that there was someone
famous in the back seat well so you
could see it like first of all I think
the windows were very tinted I think in
the two front seats were like security
guard looking people I think it's really
a quiet McDonald's in Houston they
probably don't get Escalades coming
through and by the way there was
probably more than one Escalade because
you have the camera crew and like they
probably just like saw this motorcade
and we're like oh there's definitely
someone famous in there when the window
rolled down and there was like a pause
and then they freaked out I think that
was the best moment of reality
television I've ever seen in my life it
was so pure and like him just wanting an
Oreo McFlurry extra Oreos like after
you're coming off of like saving
someone's life it was just like the best
thing I've ever seen like my heart was
full and warm that's the thing it really
highlighted like the joy what's the word
like the diverse didnõt diversity but
it's like Kim does it all like she goes
to McDonald's she meets the fans she
goes to court she goes to the White
House she's in law school like it was
just like a full circle moment of all
things Kim and she was like so cute and
you know it says a lot about and that
was like a lot of the topic in Armenia
like how you interact with your fans
like says a lot about you and I have now
fallen into an algorithm on tick-tock
because I guess a like watched and liked
a few videos of like celebrities being
mean to fans and it's literally all that
comes up on my tech-talk now and I kind
of love it because it's really
interesting to see like who takes a time
to like stop talk and take a picture and
who doesn't and I just thought Kim was
so gracious like and I expected nothing
less
she is so gracious and I feel like I'm
sure sometimes like in Armenia like it's
not ideal to be meeting the fence all
the time but I think she got so much out
of that exchange like as much as those
girls did who are like taking pictures
that was so cute maybe like another
somebody just might have been like don't
roll down the window like say no one's
in here you know like but she's just so
sweet she's just sweet as sugar she's
sweet as sugar and like that little high
pony hair moment was so cute
then we get back to Calabasas and what
happens more fertility stuff was
actually feel like I was learning a lot
like you can only see the fertility of
an egg once it's made into an embryo but
then I was thinking like obviously just
make it into an embryo like you have
Kristen but then remember that whole
court drama with Sofia Vergara where her
and her ex-husband like had embryos and
he literally like sued her for them and
he was gonna be able to like have a baby
with her without her actual permission
and then that made me think like you
never know what's gonna happen with
Tristan like don't make an embryo no but
it sounds like she's thought of all
legal possibilities and she's making him
sign paperwork that says these are not
your eggs these are my embryos you are
not the father you are a sperm donor and
he's just like okay yeah it's like
obvious that he's desperate to just get
back with her like whether that means
having to have another kid or just like
do whatever and part of me really likes
Emily thinks he's kind of pathetic and
all the ways that he just tries so hard
but then like once I'm thinking of him
as pathetic an image flashes into my
mind of him trying to make out with
Jordan Woods and then I feel like he's
less pathetic ya know it's it's bad but
you know what it's like
these are trues mom and dad and like if
trues gonna have a sibling and chloe
need sperm like and Chloe's not in a
relationship with someone else like then
I completely understand why she's doing
what she's doing yeah and I respect
Khloe's decision to want true to have
the same parents as her sibling or free
to choose your sibling yeah but I think
like that Sofia Vergara situation can't
happen because Chloe is making him sign
all of the paperwork but it's a
cautionary tale to women everywhere yeah
that was really crazy anything else that
happened this episode we got a little
bit of Rob oh yes he looks good yeah
he's like really cuting you can tell
like everyone is so happy
also we got to see Kim plan Chris's
birthday surprise and it was just the
cutest thing it was the cutest thing
when we saw it on Instagram and we
didn't get much more than we already saw
um but we got a reminder that Kim is a
precious gem and she's sweet of sugar
and it was really such a great episode
and I saw a headline this morning that
was like so annoying that was like
Kourtney makes her return to Kim Keeping
Up with the Kardashians I was like it
was two episodes yeah it's really
interesting to see how Kourtney acts
when she's on camera but not filming so
she wasn't really
um
like mic'd or anything at Chris's
birthday party and she just like has
this like mug on her face like she's
always like disappointed and even when
everyone was like crying and like joyful
with the wallpaper she literally just
had this like smug like she's just so
unhappy yeah yeah but I'm glad that
we're just seeing less of it I thought
it was such a good good episode like
really so enjoyable me too it had it all
it had it all um speaking of enjoyable
episodes key Real Housewives of New York
yes Real Housewives of New York we
finished up the night in the Hamptons
with Ramona
Ramona's house and honestly like for a
Housewives fan who's had to deal with
like Ramona's abhorrent behavior
particularly in other people's houses
for years and I realize like Ramona's
had this house in the Hamptons forever
but she's never had all the women over
like she had Sonja come like a million
times like sometimes during these days
but she's never had like a formal
weekend at her house where the cameraman
were always you know um and I kind of
know why because she's such a poor
houseguest like imagine how people would
would be in her house and we got to see
all the women like be the worst version
of themselves in Ramona's house and like
to be honest like it's retribution like
I understand she was upset and if it was
anyone else I would have agreed with her
like look what they do to her house like
there's a champagne bottle in the pool
but you know what like sorry remember
when you ripped the paint off of Durand
s [ __ ] sconces yeah but also they
didn't like to do permanent damage so
there was a lot of dirty dishes there
was tiki torches everywhere champagne
bottles in the pool maybe some broken
glasses but like you threw a party at
your house that is what happens like
also you left so you're just leaving
people to do whatever they want she left
when after the girls were naked in the
pool like she knew that it was becoming
a frat house and she just like left them
to their own devices what you think
these girls who are so drunk and rowdy
are gonna start cleaning for you yeah
you know what even if they weren't drunk
and rowdy and like they were just having
a nice evening you were left and there
was like a whole dinner party to clean
up where was didn't she hire help yeah
everywhere if it's important for you to
have a clean kitchen and that the dishes
are done in the morning like then hire
help like like during the said yeah like
Ramona's expectations and everyone in
the way she was talking to
everyone specifically Leah she's like
the new girl and she's younger than
Ramona I think we're going to feels like
she can talk to her like she talks to
Avery like it was just so disrespectful
and I just didn't understand what her
expectations were like you put out this
feast for 15 people and you didn't you
didn't keep the the housekeeper so like
who did you think was gonna clean it up
yeah she thought that the girl's worth
she saw that they work for her like
because they're they should be so
grateful that they're staying in her
house that they're also like
housekeeping gonna put in sweat equity
yeah um I want to talk about the party
at work it wasn't a party it was just a
girl hangout where Leah showed us her
drunk self
and it was so [ __ ] funny I was
literally like shook laughing like I
couldn't believe that they won they all
jumped in the pool butt naked I can't
believe that Leah got tensley to be butt
naked the throwing of the tiki torches
the screaming in the kitchen like it was
so funny and obviously like I'm curious
to see what happens next week like cuz
you know some apologies are gonna have
to be made but it was just crazy like
leah is so like I understand why she
chooses not to drink sometimes I mean in
in given the environment she was in like
I didn't think she was being that crazy
I guess there isn't that much she could
have done just sitting in someone's
house in the Hamptons but like she was a
little loud and annoying but like I
didn't think it was that bad like she's
was on the same level as Sonja no I
didn't even think she was annoying like
I thought she was genuinely hilarious
the only thing that you'll have to
apologize for it's like she was really
going in I'm like Sonja and Tinsley and
Mortimer and Morgan and she said I'm
watching up inside last night that like
she was just getting to know these girls
she didn't understand like all of that
history stuff that there is with them so
now she doesn't feel that way but then
she did so you see like the next day
like you're judging someone so hard
based on their name the way they and she
doesn't like to be judged either so
that's the only thing she needs to
apologize for like everything else it
looks like the best night ever
totally and like honestly I feel like
her and Sonja next week like get more
and more further apart from being
friends when I actually feel like they
could be really good friends yeah but I
think they're just like caught up on
these like preconceived notions of one
another that eventually they will knock
down when they were juxtaposing between
the conversation going on in the kitchen
with Dorinda and
in Ramona and I was just like could not
be less interested went outside there it
was like the best party ever happening
it was just like it was really
frustrating it's like any time you went
back in the kitchen I don't even know
what was said because I was just like do
you not know what's going on outside get
in the pool yeah Ramona was basically
saying that she knows many people who
have gotten John to ask for their phone
numbers even though Johnson a
relationship and these girls were in a
relationship and it's just annoying
because now we know that Dorinda and
John are not together so Ramona like
probably feels vindicated but what she
said was like [ __ ] up and me and
especially when like Dorinda wasn't
being combative at all like it was
literally just out of left field
yeah totally um LuAnn it's just like
getting less and less interesting
I do think it'll be fascinating to see
her journey back to drinking because I
and I have said this before this season
I didn't really think she was an
alcoholic I think she was someone who
got in trouble for alcohol and like
gotten put in timeout and was like
having as I would - I would have a hard
time being in timeout also if all my job
revolves when I'm doing cabaret filming
a TV show where all the women drink so I
don't think that she's an alcoholic but
I get what she means like it's been a
long time like just you don't know what
what the timing is supposed to be like
yeah and like she's doing so well in her
in her life it's like do you want to
bring in that variable it's probably
yeah it's probably nerve-wracking but
eventually we know that she does yeah
but she's boring right now so she's like
she's not cutting it like and not that I
want to say like the only drunk LuAnn
yes Tecate but like she used to be like
funny and dramatic and now she's just
boring I just think she thinks maybe
that she's like the new Bethenny and
Bethenny used to you know come for the
day sleep at her own house do her own
thing um and it wasn't like Bethenny was
getting crazy drunk so I think she just
thinks she doesn't have to work as hard
and that people will just want to see
her because she's LuAnn de Lesseps and
she's cabaret and she all she needs to
do is show up but that's just not the
case for her you know I don't think that
it is I just love Lee and we're like I'm
learning so much about her like last
night's episode and then after watching
um Meghan McCain talked about her like
it's obvious that she's like super woke
so like her and the tiki torches it just
like obvious cultural appropriation like
she was not into I just know she said on
on watch what happens live she was so
mad about the tiki torches and she
thought it was obvious
and Wendy McClendon the boy agreed with
her but and
didn't know and I didn't know either
that it's like a symbol of
Charlottesville and like the white
supremacist we're using tiki torches and
so like that's why she like was so angry
about them oh I just assumed it was like
a Hawaiian cultural appropriation no it
was about Charlottesville oh that's not
obvious at all I mean she two of them it
was and and then to other people it
wasn't but then I googled it immediately
and it's like very much a prominent
thing and I think also in like her drunk
State that's all she saw you know that
just sucks because tiki torches are a
really effective way to like light up a
backyard like just just outside the
symbolism like when you think about it
and like you're in a dark like backyard
and you don't of electricity like it
really is a fabulous way to look light
up a spark yeah and I think that also
when I was like doing some research
about tiki torches I think they helped
with mosquito repelling so yes like
another added bonus yeah that sucks I
can't say that if I ever have a backyard
I won't be using tiki torches because
they are just so effective but I will
know the symbolism behind it and I will
disagree with that completely yeah
totally okay um anything else on Maroni
know just fabulousness losing it was
good like I had a lot of skepticism
about the season especially given the
first episode and comparing it with the
first episode of Beverly Hills which was
like stellar but I'm feeling good yeah
I'm feeling good too I loved this
episode I thought it was like batshit
crazy it was it was great it was like
now he is like full-blown housewife cast
member I love her so much
me too we're gonna talk about to out to
handle which is brought to you by
OkCupid very appropriately if you
haven't heard about OkCupid yet we're
here to tell you why you should give it
a shot in 2020 what a lot of people
don't know about OkCupid is that they
have really changed the game by asking
you the most thoughtful questions so
that they can learn more about who you
are and what type of person you're
looking for the more questions you
answer the better they aren't finding
you matches you have something in common
with some of my favorite questions from
the OkCupid dating profile are about how
long do you want your next relationship
to last how do you feel about the 2020
election are you a cat person a dog
person do you listen to podcasts are you
a toaster and OkCupid actually works
it's the most mentioned dating app in
the New York Times wedding section which
is a fabulous statistic OkCupid is the
only app in the world that can match you
on a range of issues that you care about
from whether or not you're a dog or cat
person to how you feel about climate
change
the vilest I'm on dating apps and go to
the app where you choose what matters
OkCupid is free so we don't have a code
or you are out for you guys
just download OkCupid today go on a
great date this week and then tell us
about the great person you met will come
to the wedding
and all of us is sing and become
ordained and officiate too hot to handle
so last we spoke you were like hating
Harry and you didn't feel any particular
way about Chloe
now having finished it would love to
hear your thoughts on both those
characters so I think that Harry really
grew throughout the process he matured a
little bit and I by the end obvious a
completely shaped him and Francesca but
I would chip anyone with Francesca
because I'm obsessed with her her
personality her looks like she's just
one of she's just an it girl you know
she just has it like the show the entire
show revolves around her and like she
was she wasn't even trying to be
involved you know no I actually heard
that she was right after the show she
was put in the hospital for chronic back
pain from putting the entire show on her
back yeah exactly so wouldn't she like
wanted to be with Harry then I was fine
with him and you could see that he grew
and like but the thing is like he really
did throw her under the bus and that
first episode like there was no there
was no like he said she said it was like
he like we have the footage it was
completely him he threw her under the
bus like nobody that would have nobody
believed her that would have really
pissed me off so like I was kind of
annoyed that like they just skimmed over
it you know but I'm sure they dealt with
it since and she has posted on Instagram
they are still together so there are a
lot of people who think that they're
married because this show was filmed in
April 2019 and there's like a picture
going around of him and Francesca like
eating lunch and he's wearing a wedding
ring like on that finger and it's like a
silver band um I don't think that
they're married but it's not the
craziest thing because you know I
actually when I when the show ended I'm
like he definitely like grew up a little
bit but like he'll go home and they go
back to his fuck-boy ways and like this
eventually obviously won't work out cuz
he lives in Australia but he moved to LA
she still lives in Vancouver but that's
obviously a better commute and I really
feel like the show works for him because
he's now been in a two-year relationship
own a one-year relationship also like
she's the most beautiful girl like I've
ever seen and it's cool to see like an
Instagram girl on TV and it's like wow
she really looks like that like she for
every single angle like no makeup makeup
like she is just so stunning so I feel
like once he's like dating her like and
he goes out and say he's like tempted
like what other girl is gonna look any
better than her you know okay and I just
love how much time she and Haley like
just spent in that makeup room like
that's every time she was feeling a
scene Francesca was in that room like
doing her makeup and I think that's the
only room with air conditioning that was
just a vibe that I got and I would have
stayed in there the whole time
I really like it Haley even though she
was totally grumpycat like she just like
what we do I just yeah I wish but I was
glad that she wanted to leave and then
she left like obviously there was
nothing there for her someone who really
took up time and space on the island was
um Massimo Jesus like who are you gonna
say Nicole she made it till the end
without ever kissing or having a single
connection and not being funny or
interesting at all she didn't deserve
the money like that's [ __ ] why why
didn't she like have any sort of
connection with anyone cuz nobody by the
way no one was interested in her and
that's fine but like when the last
second to last episode when Lana came on
and sent home Cory and Madison she
should have sent home Nicole and she
should have sent home Bryce yeah but
like I guess they did they did try in
this process but like it's not their
fault but that or their person wasn't
there for them you know and like I feel
like Nicole made a lot of really good I
think I she was everyone's friend I
think they would have been really sad
also it's the difference of a few
thousand dollars like the whole thing at
the end was so stupid it was a letdown
like the money was such a big deal in
the beginning and then towards the end
when they got like less and less money
and then we're realizing more people
were coming they were splitting it like
at the end of the day wasn't enough
money to keep people from doing stuff
and the attitude of everyone in the
house like went down like when [ __ ]
Chloe kissed Cory like did no connection
like he was brand new and she just like
kissed him because she was horny like
everyone it's fine it's yeah but like
when Francesca's like actually dealing
with real feelings between Kells and
Harry like she's the devil like any time
she did something people were so rude
but then like Chiron and Rhonda did it
and they were like oh and I just want to
say sorry sure on your name is Sharon no
here's the thing when sure on Iran to do
it it is cute but like there was one
kiss that Chloe had I think it was with
Bryce that was never even mentioned by
Lana like
it was like she's so irrelevant that she
didn't even care to get like roasted by
the group um Chloe was annoying she
didn't bother me as much as she bothers
you for some reason she didn't bother me
but like the fact that she's everyone's
favorite like that's what bothers me and
that wouldn't know she's not look at the
Instagram followers she's not everyone's
favorite oh that's true but Francesca
did have a leg up because she said she'd
like 400,000 followers before she
started but yes I agree she's got two
million Oh Hugh million and last for her
Chloe Chloe's at 500,000 I just saw
Chloe was so annoying think of me man
think of me I just thought she was so
annoying and she was always on the wrong
side of history like when she was
[ __ ] coming for Francesca for going
on a date with Cory like what the [ __ ]
does Francesca oh you [ __ ] yeah I mean
that guy Cory was like such a loser um
be honest that group of three people
that came on the boat was like honestly
the boats right from loser Island they
came on the loser Cruiser Layla what was
her name Lydia Lydia Lydia yeah she was
I mean I don't know much about her but I
just know she's a woman of taste because
gave it is the the finest catch on the
island I couldn't believe David was
having such a hard time like Rhonda
turned him down Khloe turned him down I
just couldn't believe like he's actually
like immediately once he found out what
the show was about like he really
pivoted and to maybe trying to like dive
deeper he didn't need any you know um
convincing to like start this journey
like Harry did and chiron did like he
just immediately dove headfirst and like
no one liked him and like he couldn't
catch a break and then answer with like
Lydia massaging his ass which was fine
but he didn't find that deeper
connection and that made me sad yeah
that made me sad too but I'm sure I
think he had a good time and I don't
know um so overall I liked the show
I thought the premise was like a little
stupid and not really fine-tuned enough
and I don't know how they would do a
season 2 because like everyone now knows
the rules that it's like a sexless
Island um but I really liked like the
cat need initial first cast I thought
but it was without Francesca the show is
nothing I totally occur and Enron is
still together
they have been posted on Instagram I
have no idea but there was an embargo on
everyone's social media since he
yesterday so last night at 12:00
M is when um Francesca and Harry first
posted because they weren't allowed to
post literally until Wednesday of this
week yeah that makes sense
yeah I don't know we still together and
I likes that it was international too
because it added an element like in love
is blind like it made it so easy for
everyone like if we were to be together
we lived down the street like it added a
level of like seriousness to it um but
justice for Kells but I also don't think
the show was meant to form like lasting
relationships I don't think that's what
they were interested in doing it was
more so like putting temptation in front
of people and seeing if they could go
without it and then just like going home
to their regular lives like it's not
like love is blind is like we want
marriages same with The Bachelor um but
this isn't a show about love it's just a
show about like temptation I was curious
how they were monitoring whether people
are were masturbating in the shower yeah
I feel like there were definitely ways
that people could get away with that
yeah it's like I don't think it's
believable that like not one person
masturbated the entire time and cuz
wanna never called them out the sleeping
arrangements were very strange like how
there was only one room for boys and
girls and there wasn't even enough beds
like people were double bunking I saw at
one seen Bryce was sleeping on the floor
yeah that's kind of like in love island
so basically I think a lot of the show
is modeled after love island um but one
of the things is that basically every
week you pick your partner for the week
it's the person that you obviously have
feelings for um sometimes it's just
friendships but you have to sleep in the
bed with that person every night so I
think they just like did a lot of island
bunks like one bed for every two people
I think some people probably wanted to
sleep alone and therefore Bryce was on
the floor also at one point there was
more than ten people there so
interesting okay um I liked it I don't
know if we'll get another season because
it was like one of those social
experiment and vibe type things but um I
thought was good and now I follow
Francesca on Instagram I follow her too
and I thought it was good it was like it
was yesterday was the first day in
quarantine that I just like watch TV
right after the toast and just spent the
day watching TV and it was really
enjoyable this weekend I think I'm
finally gonna watch money high season 4
it's been like saving it to have
something to look forward to but I think
this weekend is the weekend money
is really good if you've never watched I
recommend I'm not my vibe I'm just
probably gonna peruse YouTube for things
I've already seen yeah no I wasn't
saying if you've never watched I was
saying toasters sorry
I know but like I would not suggest that
for you you wouldn't like it this is the
end of our episode but if you're looking
for more content we have tons of
episodes available on our patreon
channel patreon.com slash good morning
toast and all of our toasts News Network
released new episodes this week so
Olivia did an episode with any grammar
lauren elizabeth did an episode with
Claudia so loose key there's just tons
of stuff Margaret Joseph's had a new
episode Raven and Alexis had a new
episode so head over to the toast news
network Instagram if you're looking for
something new to watch and catch up on
all of our TNN shows we love you guys so
much please follow us on instagram at
the morning toast we're almost at went
okay that's our show thanks very much
listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please tell me to subscribe
this video a thumbs up
whilst available as a podcast and we're
podcast podcast sweet-ass that's not a
fire iTunes stitcher public video I
already cast bucks to all the places
where ever you listen [ __ ] that's fine
that's amore in totally five-star view
better be able something smart we are we
love you guys so much have a great
weekend stay safe and stay indoors I